[Music]
hey guys back up back up back up back up
back up back up
all the way back all the way back no one
right here no one right here
for one second
back up guys back up three feet big feet
back up back up all of you behind here
now
[Music]
back up please keep going keep going
keep going
keep going keep going
all the way over here guys all the way
over here they cut through me they're
gonna be moving all the way over here
[Music]
again i need a clear pathway
[Music]
not going to say it again we'll push it
out
[Applause]
[Music]
connor rachel from 18. man i heard about
the scuffle you had with machine gun
kelly on the carpet
i don't know the man i don't know the
man is obviously
megan to be at the at the fight so what
happened absolutely not then i don't
know i just i just showed up and i don't
know just i don't even know the guy to
be honest with you just rumors
nothing happened with me i only fight
real fighters people that actually fight
you know what i mean i certainly don't
fight little vanilla boy rappers you
know i don't even know the guy i don't
know anything about him except that he's
making [ __ ] you know what i mean you
know yourself
okay
[Music]
hey guys back up back up back up back up
back up back up back up
all the way back all the way back no one
right here no one right here
for one second
back up guys back up three feet big feet
back up back up all of you behind here
now
[Music]
back up please keep going keep going
keep going
keep going keep going
all the way over here guys all the way
over here they cut through here they're
gonna be moving all the way over here
[Music]
again i need a clear pathway
[Music]
not gonna say it again we'll push it out
[Applause]
[Music]